Citizens of Gotham, Batman is once again coming
to bust some bad guys.
And it sounds like the latest iteration of
the Caped Crusader will be more conflicted
than ever.
At least that's the word from the actor who's
set to don the cape and cowl in the upcoming
superhero flick The Batman.
Robert Pattinson recently sat down with The
New York Times' Kyle Buchanan, who took the
opportunity to ask Pattinson about his role
as the Dark Knight in the soon-to-shoot Batman
movie.
The actor was quick to praise director Matt
Reeves, and offered his own read of the notoriously
complex superhero he's about to play.
He gushed:
"I love the director, Matt Reeves, and it's
a dope character.
His morality is a little bit off.
He's not the golden boy, unlike almost every
other comic-book character.
There is a simplicity to his worldview, but
where it sits is strange, which allows you
to have more scope with the character."
The actor then revealed why he was drawn to
the character - and in doing so, he made a
head-turning comment about Batman.
Pattinson said:
"Batman's not a hero.
He's a complicated character.
I don't think I could ever play a real hero
- there's always got to be something a little
bit wrong."
By the sounds of it, Pattinson and Reeves
are apparently aiming to take the "hero" out
of the superhero genre with The Batman - which
is some of the most intriguing news we've
heard about the new movie thus far.
And that's saying a lot in a week that's also
seen The Batman cast Zoë Kravitz as Selina
Kyle - a.k.a. Catwoman - and set its sights
on Paul Dano as the Riddler.
All of that came just weeks after it was reported
that Westworld star Jeffrey Wright was in
talks to appear as Batman's Gotham City Police
Department ally Commissioner Gordon.
Though we've got to admit that it's initially
shocking to hear Pattinson say that Batman
isn't a hero, it's not exactly an earth-shattering
revelation to learn that the actor and director
Matt Reeves plan to subvert the norm.
That vision was first teased with the news
that Reeves' was scrapping Ben Affleck's script
for The Batman, and furthered when Affleck
himself was relieved of his dark watch over
the streets of Gotham.
"NOOOO!"
In spite of its initial production turmoil,
The Batman soldiered on with Reeves at the
helm - though months passed with little to
no news of what the director had in mind.
The silence finally broke earlier this year
when Reeves revealed that his movie would
be a, quote, "point of view-driven, noir Batman
tale" that sees Batman flexing his detective
skills that most films have barely touched
on.
At the time, Reeves told The Hollywood Reporter:
"I hope it's going to be a story that will
be thrilling but also emotional.
It's more Batman in his detective mode than
we've seen in the films [...] It's going to
allow his character to have an arc so that
he can go through a transformation."
When it was announced that Pattinson had been
tapped to don the mask in The Batman, the
internet nearly imploded at the news, with
the actor himself even fearing the wrath of
an insolent internet fandom.
While most of those fans were intrigued by
the thought of Pattinson in the Bat-suit,
there were plenty who were wary of the former
Twilight heartthrob bringing the requisite
charm and menace required with the dual roles
of Bruce Wayne and Batman.
But fans have little to worry about.
Pattinson has spent his post-Twilight years
forging a reputation as one of the most fiercely
devoted and adventurous actors on the planet
- a reputation he's earned by delivering show-stopping
performances in indie fare like Cosmopolis,
Good Time, High Life, and the just-released
film The Lighthouse.
Though The Batman will serve as the highest-profile
film Pattinson has appeared in in years, there's
little doubt the actor will bring the same
sort of intensity to his role as the Dark
Knight.
Sadly, it'll be awhile before we see what
comes from his enticing approach to the role.
The Batman will begin filming in early 2020,
but won't be out in theaters until June 25th,
2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.